yeah well guess what that's me I just
described me right there that's me yeah
I'm 14 years old but that's what I've
done you know yeah you can say I don't
have experience but I have had
one-on-one conversations with Gary
Vaynerchuk
with Grant Cardone with the best of the
best and that's what I'm gonna be
delivering to your team there you go
that's what I'm going to hear yeah yeah
okay welcome to fake gurus part 3 this
is Caleb Maddox and that's him on a fake
sales phone call a actual sales phone
call according to him where he makes
$10,000 and of course it's not real now
in the last video some people asked you
know don't you have better things to do
with your time no no I don't this is
this is my favorite thing to do but
secondly the reason I call them out is
because it takes away from the people
who are really doing it and so the best
thing I can the best thing I can make an
analogy to is fake martial arts
something that has been exposed and
people know now it's fake if you haven't
seen it this is this is what it looks
like so it takes away from people who
actually are like MMA fighters and stuff
like that to see people like this who
are obviously faking skills
so that's why you have to expose these
people because otherwise you see all
those students lined up around that
teacher people are paying good money to
get what they think are actual lessons
and and the guy's a fraud and those
people don't know it so you you have to
expose people for for the people who are
getting suckered into it so that's why I
do this
Caleb Maddox is a motivational speaker
young money millionaire and really want
what I want to get on him about is one
big lie he recently or he did a while
ago I guess where he says he did a
$10,000 day and what he means by that is
he got he he made a deal for ten
thousand dollars during a single sales
call and he supposedly recorded it live
the tips I give in my speech they will
they will apply and make you a hundred
grand off of that me coming up there so
basically it's like it's like you're
giving me $10,000 I'm flying up to speak
at your thing and as soon as I get there
I'm hand you a hundred thousand dollar
check
that's the ROI of this deal you know
that's a great question why would you
pay a fourteen-year-old ten thousand
dollars and the reason why not know you
know what you're right you know you
probably shouldn't pay me fourteen
you probably shouldn't pay me ten grand
I'm only 14 but I just have a friend but
I think he'd do a better job than me he
can come down and speak for you he
actually he just got did an interview in
Entrepreneur Magazine he also did an
interview in Forbes he didn't interview
and Huffington Post he did an interview
on national television he just spoke
with Gary Vaynerchuk you know he speak
when Darren Hardy as well he's also
written a best-selling book would you be
interested in having him come out yeah
well guess what that's me I just
described me right there that's me
yeah I'm 14 years old but that's what
I've done you know yeah you can say I
don't have experience but I have had
one-on-one conversations with Gary
Vaynerchuk with Grant Cardone with the
best of the best and that's what I'm
gonna be delivering to your team let's
make this happen man there you go that's
what I'm going to hear yeah yeah okay
what's funny to me is he oscillate
between bro and sir all the time yes yes
sir bro come on bro come on bro I'm
gonna make the hundred ganja grin so
basically it's like
it's like you're giving me $10,000 I'm
flying up to speak at your thing and as
soon as I get there I'm hand you a
$100,000 check okay so a little
background so so if you didn't if it's
not completely 100% obvious that's not a
real sales call that's not how real
sales calls go people don't flip on a
$10,000 decision based on you listening
off your resume the reason I know that
is because I did new home sales I was in
new home sales for about a year which is
not forever by any stretch of the
imagination but it is enough to know
what what what can be done and what is
not in the realm of possibility no one
flips on a ten thousand dollar deal
because you listed your resume to them
arrogantly that just doesn't happen
nobody flips because you promised them
and a hundred thousand ROI without
explaining how they're going to get that
ROI the other thing is look he goes it's
the seventh or eighth call this is what
our seventh or eighth call man nobody
nobody does sales deals like that why
would you be on the phone for the
seventh or eighth time with somebody
what you can't decide you people decide
after their second or third interaction
with a Salesman in fact they usually
decide the first time on the way home
and the second or third time are just
confirmation to get there their worries
out of the way nobody gets on seven or
eight business calls I mean it's obvious
the kid the kid is making it up so I
don't feel like I have to go on more
than that but the reason I actually
wanted to get this video out of the way
is the next video we're gonna talk about
another fake sales call someone bigger a
much more higher profile so I wanted to
get the idea in your head that these
fake sales calls occur just like people
are faking martial arts and all sorts of
other things to sell courses people are
faking sales calls in order to in order
to sell themselves anyway just uh I hope
you enjoyed another episode of fake guru
this time we have Caleb Maddox with his
fake phone calls
and yeah I hope you enjoy I'll see you
next time
[Music]
and we were scary we were shaking
waiting at the intersection looking at
each other's face
[Music]
the crazies in the street only kiss we
know it's how we kind
there's a fraction of a brain cell Shane
the Nexus but we are but for small gear
in the mirror someone
laughing lucky that you love me and I'm
glad we never fight and I'm lucky that I
like myself this late at night I doubt
so I'm scared to look at mirrors just in
case I start
[Music]